IF ONLY THERE WAS ANOTHER WAY!
Whattup shorties, short Jules here for a DNews
short.
I am five-foot-eight, which is below the average
height for an adult American male, roughly
five-foot-nine-and-a-half.
For our entire lives, we’ve been told that
there is nothing we can really do about being
short.
For most everything else, there is plastic
surgery, or medication, or some other solution,
while us shorties are stuck with shoe lifts
and pinstripes.
But what if I told you vertically challenged
friends that there is a way to grow taller,
even as a fully grown adult.
The only catch?
Well, you have to break your legs.
A medical procedure, called “distraction
osteogenesis”, can actually lengthen your
bones by a few inches, and was originally
developed to treat those with uneven leg lengths,
or dwarfism.
This is essentially done by breaking the bone,
then separating or stretching it for the bone
to heal in a longer position.
Today it is mostly used to treat disorders
of the face, where the jaw or chin or skull
may not be the right size, or growing in the
right direction.
But in China, this surgery saw popularity
around the early 2000s, and is still being
done around the world as a cure for, well,
shortness.
There are three stages to the heightening
procedure.
The first is called the “latency phase”.
The legbone, usually the tibia, is either
fully separated, or just cut into what is
essentially a fracture.
The second, ‘distraction phase’ introduces
a separating device, often a Ilizarov apparatus.
This surrounds the leg and bolts into the
bone, allowing not only stabilization, but
separation.
Each day, the device separates the two parts
of the tibia by about one millimeter.
While the device separates the bone, a callus
forms at the site of the break.
As the bone is spread farther and farther
apart, the callus is resorbed and replaced
by a collagen structure.
Collagen is a protein that forms the connective
tissues in our bodies.
New blood vessels grow around this collagen
and special cells called osteoblasts move
in to create the actual bone material.
At this stage though, the bone material has
not mineralized, or become fully hard.
Once the desired length is reached, which
often tops out at just a few inches, the final
phase begins: consolidation.
In this phase, the bone material mineralizes
-- and this takes about a month for each centimeter
in length!.
The now slightly taller patient just has to
undergo several months of physical therapy
to learn how to walk again.
As you might imagine, the whole process is
very painful.
And, according to a study published in 2014
by the European Journal of Orthopaedic Surgery
and Traumatology, 77% of patients experience
complications, and 70% of those complications
were major, including axis deviation, or leg
alignment, hardening of joints, and psychological
problems.
The Hospital for Special Surgery in the US
claims to have added up to a full foot in
height to those with dwarfism, although most
people are only able to achieve a height boost
of a few inches.
So, yes, you can get taller.
But in most cases, you might not want to.
So how much force does it take to break a
bone anyway?
We answer that question in this video.
And if you have any other bone or body questions
for us, let us know down below in the comments
and don't forget to subscribe for more DNews
everyday.